- It's like two breasts,
they you like
- No!
- you put your head in
between the breasts.
(upbeat music)
- We have been a couple for two years.
- About a year.
- Almost two years, yeah almost two years.
- Four years.
- This is going to be
weirdly sexual I think.
- Is this a sex ramp?
- No, it just covers up
those rough, like boney edges.
- It's like two breasts,
then you like
- No!
- you put your head in
between the breasts.
- I feel like my dog would
just hump it (laughs)
and then I'm supposed
to put my face on that?
He he, no.
(giggling)
- I know how it works.
(muffled laughing)
(laughing)
- Oh, look there's a picture!
- I know.
They're cuddling.They're 69-ing.
- I think it's like this.
Now come in here.
- I feel like
this is like, entrapment.
- So your arm doesn't hurt?
- Not yet.
- How is that?
- Awful.
- Yes.
- This is a yes product.
- I'm mixed. I'm going to say no.
Smittens: Walking mittens
for friends and lovers.
I just threw up in my
mouth just a little bit.
- This is kind of cute!
- As long as
you never go out in public. (laughing)
- Yeah this is corny.
(both laughing)
- Put your hand in this big bad boy.
- I need my hands to talk.
- Yeah, she does, she's very expressive.
- I like this for in the house
cause my hands are always freezing.
- Yeah, but then, like, your
hands are going to start
swaeting on the inside like an oven.
- Oh I hate that!
- (laughing)
- Oh, I hate that!
- I knew it!
- Yeah, it's pretty moist already.
- It's not really that convenient.
- I feel like this is
what you do in pockets.
- I would absolutely not buy this,
this is a no.
- [Both] This is a yes.
- Oh no.
- (laughing)
- This is, I am not into this.
- Yeah this is...
- We're not, this is not how we roll.
- Uhm, Mickey Mouse hands
are pointing at your vagina,
so that's comforting.
- Ho ho!
- Oh yeah, that's vulgar!
Uh oh, I think I might
get it now. (laughs)
- No.
- Basically it's not like if some girl
started getting up all in that
I'd like, "it's ok I just own that."
- I just, I just... Don't touch the dick.
- I would rather you,
every time we pass a female,
for you to go, "that's mine, that's mine,"
than to wear this.
- This is a no.
- This is a maybe.
- What the (beep) is this?
No. No.
- (laughing) Hell no.
- Oh.
- This is like a big body condom.
- I'm confused about how much time
you would actually spend in these.
Like cause you put them on...
- Oh, I can't wait to get
in those panties, literally.
(laughing)
- Oh!
- Cute!
(giggling)
Stand up.
- I can't,
we're going to rip them.
- These are a hazard!
- Hey, you know on second thought,
- This might...
- This might, ah, be worth it.
- I feel like a lot of these
things were just reaching.
Like, if you have a good relationship,
like, we know how we cuddle,
we know how we like, get things going.
I don't need weird underwear and pillow
to tell me how to do it.
- They kind of brought us together
in ways we didn't expect.
- I think if your girlfriend
likes these products and you don't,
it could possibly be a red flag.
- Or a red smitten.